[Music]
I'm Donna melegari I'm a product manager
on the server list team I work on K
native eventing and App Engine flex so
why don't you take turns introducing
yourselves sure is the song I'm Morgan
Holman I'm also a product manager on the
service team I work on our event-driven
infrastructure and products so when
you've used a cloud function and you've
triggered it off of a GCS bucket a
real-time database transaction or a fire
store collection change that's the the
work I've been doing hi my name is
Carolina Nowitzki I am a product manager
on four server lists networking so I
manage the networking features for App
Engine called functions and Cauldron my
name is Michael Abdul Malik I'm a
software engineer working on
surveillance infrastructure so it's the
same infrastructure behind app engine
standard cloud run and Google cloud
functions hi my name is matt saldo I am
the product manager for App Engine
standard and I am a mediocre ruby
developer alright so one of the things
we've realized this week is that server
list means different things to different
people in fact some people have been
saying you've launched a new product
that's not server list so yes that's
totally serverless so we're not going to
answer and debate what server list isn't
isn't but instead what I'm going to do
is ask and write each panelist to talk
about why they are personally excited
about serverless and I'll go last so why
don't you start Morgan why are you
excited about serverless sure so I'm
super excited about surplice I mean I'm
a slam a service product manager so I'm
somewhat biased but you know that devs
that dev keynote yesterday was called
get to the fun part right and I think
that's what service represents for a lot
of developers it is the business logic
the business value versus all the
mundane yet very very important
operational things like patching os's
and configuring web servers and
horizontal scaling we just abstract all
that away for you and we see examples of
this we've got customers on cloud
functions on Google App Engine that are
serving millions of end-users with
ridiculously small operations teams
like one to two people and so that just
shows you how productive how lean a
developer team can be when it doesn't
have to think about infrastructure and
so I'm super excited about broadening
that so products like cloud run that
lets you bring many many more things to
service so that all developers can
represent those benefits of service
parent and you know architecture service
architecture so one thing that excites
me about surrealist is you only pay for
what you use and so I'll tell you a
story I joined the App Engine team about
three years ago and so I've worked on a
number of features for App Engine and
typically but when we're close to
releasing I create a personal test
account with my personal email because I
just want to make sure to use it like a
regular user and I test the feature and
then we ship it and so recently I
started working on BBC connectivity and
so I created a personal test project and
I created a couple VMs so that I have
something to connect to and I send out
the link to a couple of other people and
at the end of the month I go to Bill and
it was $250 to my personal account and I
said what is this I've never gotten a
bill in three years that I've worked on
App Engine for testing these things and
then I realized oh sir well this is
great what I'm really excited about is
just how easy it is to build
applications and a serval is God more
powerful over the years right there's we
have it a bunch of limitations
especially in the earlier versions of
App engines and say cloud functions we
had a concurrency limit and there were
you know a fixed number of languages
that were expanding but there's still
some kind of limitations there but we're
now getting into like much much lower
limitations in cloud run and and that
just makes it there's a wider room of
applications you can develop while still
getting the benefits of my colleagues
earlier mention in terms of not having
to think at all about any operations
aspect yeah so you know it's it's almost
become trite but it really is the case
that every business is becoming a
software company and I really think for
the majority of businesses serving us is
the right solution for them unless you
are innovating at a very low level of
computer
why bother dealing with servers or os's
I was talking to a customer yesterday
who's on App Engine and they are a self
a book self-publishing business
they let ourselves and they have a three
person development team very very small
and they're able to do that because of
service and the productivity that it
provides them and enabling businesses
like that really is what gets me excited
and makes me psyched to get out of bed
today and show up to work and make it
easier for those kinds of companies yeah
for me it's something similar I've
worked in the server list space for over
three years not all of it at Google and
I've worked in programming languages and
developer tools my entire career and the
big aha moment for me about why server
list was great is when I had a lot of
client developers come up to me and say
I have never built an application that
connects to something before not
end-to-end I was always writing the
client someone else was writing the
service and I have never done anything
on the server before and I walked up and
I used a functions product and now I'm
productive now I can build an end-to-end
application I can work on the parts I
know which is the client and the server
stuff is so simple that I can manage
that all myself
so it really eases the burden of having
to do something on the server it makes
it a lot more accessible for more
developers and even for developers who
could build a complex server application
you don't have to you get to focus on
the fun stuff as they were saying
in the developer keynote yesterday all
right so I'm going to open up I'm going
to ask us and panel questions and then
we'll get to Q&A so we're gonna do about
maybe 15 minutes of pre-canned questions
and then we'll take questions from you
so Morgan this week we launched cloud
run can you tell us what it is and how
is it different from cloud functions
sure it's a cloud run you've probably
heard about it I was in I think - you
were two or three keynotes actually
actually show of hands who has seen
cloud run demos this week Oh
for those of you who haven't you know
watch Michaels talk very impressive
so cloud runs so what it is
it is a product that allows you to run
HDPE driven containers in a service
fashion so what does that mean it means
that if you can build a container if it
can be hid via HDPE you can run it
without worrying about any of the
infrastructure so all the provisioning
of the infrastructure all the
configuration all the scaling Google
worries about that you worry about your
code in your container and so that that
probably seems very interesting but why
is it important it's important because
historically one of the biggest barriers
to adoption of service for some of our
other products like Google App Engine or
cloud functions has been that customers
haven't had as much control as they
needed over the runtime now let's be
honest app engine and functions support
a ton of different languages and
runtimes so many many things fit in to
fit very neatly into the service box but
if your app didn't and the worst case
was when you had one tiny little thing
like like I need one library that I just
can't use with App Engine or with
functions then you were completely shut
out of the service vision and so the
great thing about cloud run is that
because you can bring a container you
can basically run anything right so that
that that key barrier has now been
broken down and we've broadened the set
of workloads that are dressed about by
service which really really excites me
cloud functions is a much more curated
and opinionated product in that we
Google provide you with the runtime now
again we support many many runtimes many
many languages we've got you know Java
Go Python node so many developers can
use functions it's not it's not a huge
limitation obviously as I said before
cloud run lifts this limitation but if
your thing does fit if your workload
does fit into a cloud functions runtime
then it's a much more productive much
faster way of developing because you
just worry about what's between those
two curly braces you just worry about
the business logic the application logic
and you leave everything else to Google
so I'd say that's the big difference
between cloud running and cloud
functions I do want to talk about the
functions framework which we also
announced a couple days
to go so the functions framework is it's
kind of like the best of both worlds in
a sense and that it allows you to write
function code so again just worrying
about the you know what's between those
two curly braces not worrying about any
of the rest
but however run it anywhere and and and
be very very portable and in that the
functions framework is essentially a
library or a set of files that you would
put in your directory and what you're
developing and it takes care of all the
configuration that's needed to do a
build to build that container that can
then run on cloud run and then run on
cloud run on gke can then run anywhere
that key native which is the open API
specification for cloud run run so you
could run it on any any kubernetes
cluster running Kay native so it could
be on purim it could be on AWS you know
beyond as your wherever you want to run
that so it's kind of the best of both
worlds and that you just focus on the
application logic yet you get the
portability and the flexibility of
having a container that runs anywhere
great alright so Morgan you mentioned
that Michael had a great talk about this
he did a scale demo that everybody is
talking about on Twitter and where you
scaled up to I think it was how many
knows ten thousand or ten thousand nodes
in less than 10 seconds so why don't you
talk about how we did this scaling and
what kind of what kind of scale we're
seeing here in cloud run that is really
unparalleled in this industry sure
so with serverless were close they tend
to be bursty and we wanted customers to
be able to use our server list products
and and not have to worry about like do
I need to pre spin kind of instances do
I need to send some artificial workload
to kind of get more instances ready for
any any kind of event that I know is
coming up and so we wanted to really
kind of push the boundaries on rapid
fast scaling of of instances based on
customer workloads that customers don't
have to think about you know any
capacity or instances rewarming etc and
the way we've done we've kind of pushed
a boundary in cloud run and I just want
to know that the same infrastructure
powers all of our three surrealists
products and so we've kind
enabling it first in cloud run but we'll
get it soon in cloud functions and app
engines billing model makes us a bit
difficult to introduce there but we're
gonna have this in cloud functions as
well but to Donna's question so how do
we how do we scale the 10,000 instances
in a matter of you know 5 10 seconds the
way we do this is when a request comes
to our networking front ends the front
ends go to a small set of application
servers to see if there's an available
instance that can handle the request or
if these application servers can start a
new instance to handle the requests now
if the application servers are busy
because they already have too many
instances the networking front ends
we'll try an ever expanding group of
application servers to start an instance
in order to look for an instance that
has available capacity and kind of the
the key thing that makes this work is
that the all the different networking
front ends and we have thousands of them
in each region in a decentralized
managed man are used consistent hashing
so that they're going to the same set of
application servers for a particular
service and revision as the other
nothing in front ends without any
communication so there's no centralized
scheduling or centralized load balancer
that can either be a bottleneck for
scaling or an availability bottleneck
and so you know we as we try bigger and
bigger sets of application servers to
start instances in that kind of
simultaneously lets us scale quickly but
also avoid too many cold starts because
you could you know one way to do rapid
scaling is to just randomly go to any
application server and if you have
thousands of them
you're gonna incur a lot of cold towards
more than you need and so as we kind of
go and ever expanding groups and as long
as the application servers can respond
quickly and say hey I'm busy go to
another application server then we can
rapidly scale in a matter of seconds to
thousands of instances right and the
reason this matters the cold start is
the time it takes when there's nothing
running to actually getting a response
right and so you want customers are
going to response right away so you want
Colo cold start and before server listen
before this fast scale out or customers
would do and you know an other cloud
as I worked in they would they would pre
provision they're like oh we have a big
sale coming up or it's Black Friday
let's let's allocate and I'm seeing some
nods in the audience you know let's
allocate you know thousands of VM is in
advance so that we're ready and what
happens is you have to do all this
capacity planning in advance you pay for
capacity you're not using if you're
wrong if you if you've under provisioned
now you're really stuck because you have
to wait you know you know minutes for
new capacity to start up so that's why
this scale out is so valuable and it's
one of those things that makes
herbalists actually useful in practice
when you have a lot of load coming to
your service so I recommend watching the
video for Michaels talk it's really
fascinating so now the Munch new product
and of course what new product launches
everyone asks does this mean you're not
working on the old products anymore and
the answer is no we are still working on
the old products and if you look at our
blog post you can see we have a lot of
new improvements in cloud functions as
well as a pitch and Matt is the product
manager for App Engine so why don't you
tell us about what we've released for
App Engine this week yeah that's right
so we got a whole paragraph in the blog
post about our service offerings but
really development is very active on App
Engine we release a lot of really fun
new things so some of you may say who is
who is an App Engine user like is
running something on App Engine good
like about a quarter of the audience
great so last year we released second
generation runtime for App Engine these
are built on the same infrastructure
that cloud run is built on under the
covers they run actually a docker
container but you're not exposed to that
and these unshackled app engine from the
previous constraints where you can run
any language library you have open
network access which believe it or not
you did not have in the first engine of
App Engine and so basically you can run
and any you know and any code you don't
write your code specifically for App
Engine which you did in the past and so
on Tuesday we announced several new run
times we have PHP 7/2 and GA python 37
and GA note 10 and we also have
Rubi in alpha and Java 11 and alpha it
didn't make the blog post but right
about now or certainly a go 112 is also
going into beta so we have a slew of new
languages it's really awesome but almost
more importantly and Carolyn's gonna
talk about more of this is bpc Connect
for App Engine where you can have an app
engine app connect to services that are
running in your Google Cloud V PC so
yeah that's right that's right so the
biggest request we had on on it the
second generation runtimes was the
ability to to access a cache because the
second ten runtimes do not use the
legacy App Engine services like the
memcache surface that was bundled with
App Engine originally so now it's really
easy you spin up a VPC connector you
spin up your reticent cloud memory store
and you've got an awesome cache it's
plain vanilla Redis it works great one
final thing that is really exciting that
also didn't make the blog post but many
of you will be hearing about this for
the first time is this quarter we're
going to be doubling the memory on all
second generation runtimes
at the same price so whatever the memory
is on the instance now you'll be getting
double that no change in price so really
exciting it's a great product we've
designed the second generation runtimes
to be future compatible with cloud run
so if you are shy about using a beta
product no problem develop on App Engine
and then it's going to be an incredibly
simple like almost a one-button
migration if you ever want to use cloud
run in the future right yeah everyone
got really excited about VPC connectors
this is a really off request feature we
finally made it happen we can if you
want to plug VPC connectors go ahead now
and Karolina is the one who made this
happen so why don't you tell us about
the feature we launched and why it's
important beyond the case that matches
talked about alright so if you use App
Engine
chances are like most customers use more
than one of our cloud products right so
there are many use cases where you
actually need to use you want to use App
Engine or cloud functions so
front end basically but it needs to talk
to something that's running in your V PC
perhaps you have a GCE VM that's running
some off-the-shelf software that isn't a
good match for server lists and you need
to call that from App Engine or perhaps
you run it you wrote some services in
gke because you needed to use GPUs and
you need to access that from cloud
functions or perhaps you have an
on-premise database that's connected to
your V PC network via cloud VPN and you
want to access that from your App Engine
app as your storage layer so for all
these use cases in the past the options
were limited you had to basically give
the resource in your V PC network a
public IP address and that's how you
connect it to it it's as if it was
running like there was no advantage to
the fact that they were both running in
Google Cloud so what we have launched
now is we have a feature called
serverless V PC access and it's now in
beta the way you use this as you create
a V PC connector in the same region as
your app and in the same V PC as the
things you're trying to access then you
redeploy your app or function so just a
new version specifying the name of the
connector and from then on if in your
code you call a make a request to a
private IP that request is going to go
to the V PC connector and from there
travel through the V PC according to
however the V PC network is already set
up so it's going to respect all of your
firewall rules it's going to work with
cloud VPN and it's going to reach its
destination so now you can use cloud
memory store which previously you
actually couldn't use because cloud
memory store doesn't let you have public
eye piece and you can use cloud
functions in App Engine with compute
engine gke without having to make those
resources public so it improves your
security it also lowers latency a little
bit so it's super cool it's a great
feature try it out we're all really real
excited about it unblocks lots of
scenarios so you know there's two
versions of cloud run there's a cloud
run hosted fully managed version and
there's a cloud run on G hey it's
basically the same developer experience
on either but you can if you run on the
GK version that you're managing the
kubernetes cluster yourself if you're
writing on hosted cloud run we manage
things for you so Michael can you tell
us what do we manage on behalf of
customers what worry do we take away
from customers sure
so I mean Jake EE we are managing some
of the operations for you but you still
have to have a JK cluster you know and
so with the hosted cloud run you don't
have to have a G key cluster at all or
if you have a G key cluster for other
use cases but you don't want to kind of
mix those workloads and that's remains
on our internal hosted platform we can
scale up faster on our internal version
of cloud one and so that zero 10k kind
of scaling demo that Donna mentioned
earlier that is we do not scale that
fast yet on JK easy you wouldn't get
that scaling performance and so that's
kind of another thing that that is an
advantage of using the hosted version of
course we are working on making J key
scalability faster both for this use
case for cloud run on G key as well as
other customer use cases on Jake EE but
the kind of the technology that's
underlying cloud 1 hosted is it's been
easier to make it scale up faster you
know although there is no there's no
exposed kind of versions you have to
think about in terms of node versions or
jke versions master or node versions and
so and the cloud one hosted you there
really is no operational aspect that you
have to think about all of that stuff is
behind it runs on our internal kind of
data that data centers that are for
journaling Google's so all of the kind
of security operating system image stuff
all of that is hidden from you and we
take care of of doing that if we have to
update our own servers that is done
transparently to you the request routing
will find
and have an available version if there's
any server failures node failures all of
that is hidden from you all right thank
you very much thank you for all your
questions
[Applause]
[Music]